now it's going to be another crunch week
for the government the Prime Minister
needs to sell her brexit plan to both
her own cabinet and then to European
leaders a job made all the harder by the
calls from David Davis four cabinet
members to rebel well joining us now is
the party's deputy chairman James
cleverly thanks very much for being with
us this morning and we just mentioned I
don't we the former brexit secretary
calling on members of the cabinet to
exert their collective responsibility
and effectively mutiny against and the
checkers deal now you are a brexit
supporting member of the government so
are you gonna heed his call well I'm not
remember the government so my position
is a party position the chair of the
party but from the kind of person who
has in mind possibly I don't they but
the kind of people that are sitting
around the cabinet say well have got a
fantastic position to put their ideas
across to influence the direction of
government that's what cabinet
decision-making is all about they have
got the ear of the Prime Minister and
the lead negotiator in terms of in terms
of Dominic Raab so they should use that
position to put their ideas forward and
I would suggest has a much more
constructive and helpful way or
influencing the direction of the
negotiations with the EU so what what
direction would you like them to
influence it in well I think the the
Prime Minister's position is clear
unambiguous and there's someone that
campaigned passionately for for brexit
I'm very comfortable with which is that
we want a deal we do want to deal it's
good for us it'll be good for the EU but
we want a deal that sees the integrity
of the United Kingdom maintained and
that means no carving off Northern
Ireland away from the rest of the United
Kingdom we are a single country and
we'll negotiate in that but of course we
do want a pragmatic trading security
social relationship with our you know
closest friends in the world you've very
loyally standing by Theresa May though I
mean you swallowed checkers and some of
the concern now is about this proposed
back stock plan which would effectively
see the UK remaining in a customs union
are you worried about that could you
accept that well there's a lot of
speculation and a lot of people getting
very hot under the collar about what
they think
might be well within the Secretary's
been talking about it this week but at
the point the point the Prime Minister
has made is that the say that we have
certain red lines and one of them is
that we are not going to stay
indefinitely in a customs union the
other is that we are not going to see
Northern Ireland carved off from the
rest the United Kingdom these are things
I campaigned on things I'm very
comfortable with and things that I know
she's seeking to deliver in our
negotiation I mean you say that it's a
red line that we don't remain
indefinitely in a customs union and
that's pretty Willie I mean that just
means it is not gonna last forever I
mean as a breakfast here surely you need
a bit more reassurance than that well my
my position and one of the reasons why I
campaign for breaks it as did lots of
people is that I think we have fantastic
opportunities to engage more broadly
with the world I'm half Sierra Leonean I
got friends and family in in West Africa
incredibly they were incredibly pleased
to see the Prime Minister engaging with
Africa and her recent visit there are
some fantastic opportunities to trade
with both mature democracies sorry
mature economies and emerging economies
and we absolutely have to be free to
take advantage of those relations which
means not they take time they take time
to put in place and as long as we are
able to sign and implement those trade
deals as they come on stream then I
think the precise timing of how long
we're in a temporary customs arrangement
is is is something that can be up for
debate as long as when those
arrangements come on stream and they
won't be instant they'll be quick we're
not instant we're in a position we can
take advantage of them okay now I want
to talk to you about Universal quite
have been talking to and and I can Smith
about it earlier in the program and this
week the Work and Pensions Secretary s
move a admitted that some people will be
worse off and because of universal
credit the resolution foundation saying
three million working families could be
losing more than two thousand pounds a
year I mean is the concept of party at
risk of turning into the nasty party
again well I saw some not all because
we're in and out of makeup but I saw a
lot of this stuff in all Italian their
aim was saying about about the
foundation of universal credit and he is
absolutely right any benefit system is
going to be complicated it's going to be
expensive and it's going to be
something that needs to be delicately
handled that's a universal truth about
all benefits situations the benefits
raising that we had before Universal
Credit was cumbersome it was complicated
it was Byzantium it encouraged almost
errors and when those errors made in
good faith by the recipients happened
there were its clawback putting people
into a really difficult place
disincentivizing work it was not a good
system Universal Credit is an infinitely
better system but and the point that he
had made needs to be well resourced
which is why I'm very pleased the
public's committed to three billion in
terms the implementation for the next
phase of Universal Credit we have seen
people getting into work which is one of
the the real underpinnings of Universal
Credit in record numbers and the people
here you can't just say that's all done
to Universal quite no no is no
absolutely it's not all down to
Universal Credit but the whole point of
Universal Credit was that incentivized
people going into work so they felt
confident that if they took a job or a
better job or more hours or a pay rise
that it would always make financial
sense to them and actually would you
like to see more money in the budget
then well I mean we need to make it work
government's already committed to to
money to make sure the rollout of
Universal Credit is effective there was
always that kind of pause and review
system built in so that any difficulties
with implementation we recognized are
always going to be difficulties could be
addressed resolved and we move forward
and the important thing and you it was
right the you call the labor out on this
they have no credible alternative plan
well that may not some people would
argue that the actual policy is the
important thing rather than your
positions and perspective and I'm also
keen to talk to you about your brief as
the Conservative Party chairman yes sir
very briefly Godfrey bloom is he
remember the Conservative Party no okay
that's a very simple Clarisse in Flores
thank you and now there's a report by
concept of home that I wonder if you're
slightly more concerned about that
you're struggling to recruit good
candidates in key marginal seats we're a
West apparently so dissatisfied with the
people who put them forward that they've
asked you to reopen and applications
again I mean are you actually on an
election footing
well we are building towards an election
footing we made absolutely
the changes that we that we are putting
through in central office that initiated
by Sir Patrick McLaughlin continued by
Brandon Lewis who obviously is my boss
that these are a long term reform
program to make sure that the
conservative election winning machine is
just fat it's an election winning
machine but we've always said that was
going to take time we can do it properly
the people that we're asking to put
themselves forward for some you know
tough marginal constituencies excuse me
you know these are these are these are
jobs these are candidates that are going
to have to work those constituencies for
a number of years now we recognize that
that is a imposes degree of pressure
it's a long commitment
not everyone can put themselves forward
for that we have some outstanding
genuinely outstanding people on the
candidates list and you know we want to
see them get selected and ultimately
elected so can you can you rule out an
election if the deal is voted down if
you're so ready well my job at central
office is to make sure we're ready to
fight elections whenever his local
government elections regional government
elections police and crime Commissioner
elections and the general election when
it comes that's what we working to we're
going to make sure we're ready to fight
any elections that come over the next
few years
okay now and some people see your role
is trying to shake off the slightly
stuffy image the Conservative Party
sometimes has you're very vocal on
Twitter for example so in that spirit I
thought that we could end with a bit of
a quick fire round know how you get
quickfire quizzes have always been my
undoing
but football or rugby rugby storms they
all strongly Daniels storms well I've
got my wife got a cellphone storms II oh
really okay and Trump or Obama Obama
Obama interesting Canada or Norway
Canada full English or continental
breakfast what do you think this is the
stomach of a full English breakfast fan
Merkel or Mackel oh I admire them both
and they've both got a really difficult
one but I think instinctively I think
angler Merkel because she's had to deal
with
a considerably more challenging
situation in terms of binding that
country together in some difficult times
okay well I think you came through that
relatively on stage perhaps we'll see
we'll see what the reaction is and James
cleverly thank you